what's the holdup they say in a sport an
event called a bullet no no need to
torture we're not animals you know let
her go Elizabeth tell them you can get
him back say I can get you back to
rapture let's just say it I can get you
back to rapture put the gun down
No what was that you said about rupture
I could get you back to rupture how you
plan on doing that sister you some kind
of magician suture what tell him
suture suture him and how do you know
that slant-eyed wonder you're his lab
assistant I'm his lab assistant if it
escaped your notice Andrew Ryan's song
costs five thousand fathoms below is
shining city elder su Chun proposed to
get us back that's between me that's
between me and the slant and the slit
but if I do this the girl goes with me
little sisters are worth their weight in
gold she's not up for negotiation last
time I checked back in the city they
making little sisters by the Dozen
that's a right fairy tale you've dreamed
up sister but if you're lyin we can just
as well kill you tomorrow down here we
got not at the boat time in case I need
to get hold you if you see sue charm
tell him atlas says he hasn't forgotten
them
you